BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Good morning, motherfluffers!
Another beautiful day is upon us!
Are there any sleepyheads out there?
Hi!
You there!
Wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Are you awake yet?
Wipe those crusty eyes and let's get going!
Because an AsaMoco Live is about to begin!
Just what kind of news stories are waiting for us today?
Let's take a look.
Well, back behind my head here being all noisy, we have our live spectators and commenters!
Good morning, live spectator commenters!
Good morning!
It's you, yes!
Oh, natsukashii!
Oh, BAU BAU!
Oh my gosh!
Yes, well, we have lots of lovely commenters from our lovely commentators.
Well, my gosh.
We do have some breaking news.
Well.
There has been a terror in the community recently.
A spherical yet strangely festive white mass has been reported breaking into homes and assaulting individuals.
Have you seen anyone like this?
This nasty criminal?
Well, if you have, I'm sorry.
The details are
Rather graphic, but after some big sloppy doggy kisses from the intruder, there are reports of the victims hallucinating and seeing a white Christmas.
There was a high uptick in cases that occurred on Christmas Eve as well.
According to our resident expert, F,
This style of breaking entry is very, very rude.
It's very heinous.
It does not follow the proper rules and regulations that one should be mindful of when performing such an ancient Japanese tradition, such as some that begin with a yo.
There must be pure emotions and empathy behind it, and there must be beauty, but there is no love in this heart of the criminal.
What are you talking about, Expert F?
Maybe Expert F isn't as much of an expert as we thought, huh?
Wow!
What do I spectator commenters have to say here, huh?
A fluffy expert.
Are we sure this is an expert?
Maybe just a very fluffy mind.
Kusa.
Guilty.
Very scared.
Please make sure to be very safe from the Spherical Intruder, okay Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Well, there is some sad news to share with you today.
YouTube has been grumpy and rough
Ms.
Fuwawa Abyssgard and Ms.
Mococo Abyssgard of FUWAMOCO Channel on YouTube have had their first major run-in with the platform.
There is some unfair punishment going on.
After doing a very lovely, very beautiful visual novel style Christmas Eve stream, YouTube has been funny.
And well, it noticed some of the
Exciting.
Game-like event CG sprinkled through the stream.
Well, it was very, very exciting for the Ruffians.
That excitement also has reached YouTube as well and now they feel like it's not suitable for advertisers and have limited the ads on the video.
YouTube!
What are you doing?
Hi!
Well, according to the expert elf, this is something deeply ingrained in what makes YouTube YouTube.
You could say maybe that this is just a part of YouTube's animalistic instincts, but it's still horrible.
You know, YouTube helps make smiles, but it can also easily take them away.
Good thing there are some Demon Guard Dog sisters out there to protect your smile, huh?
You might win this one today, YouTube.
But not forever!
BAU BAU!
Moving on to our next story.
The bad news continues.
The archiver of hololive English -Advent-, Shiori Novella, has fallen.
She just released her first cover song ever of Whisper Whisper Whisper by Azari, which is super exciting!
In fact, it's super duper exciting!
It's her first song cover!
BAU BAU BAU!
Right!
It's time to celebrate!
Hai!
But, uh...
Shiori's release method was also very unique.
So unique that when there were reports of it coming in, it seemed like we were two weeks late to the party!
But no, that wasn't the truth!
We contacted Ms.
Shiori Novella for a comment on the matter, and she told us that it was the fault of a mysterious Kuroi Novella!
This Kuroi Novella character likes the darkness of a silent room.
And so, when they're clicking around YouTube in the darkness, they accidentally set the video from private to public.
What a mysterious figure.
Well, we can thank them for the accidental gift of Shiori's first cover song!
But you know,
We would've liked to celebrate the release together with Shiori and all the noveletes.
Good you!
Good eye novella!
Well, what do our spectator commenters have to say here, huh?
Whoops.
Whoops is right.
She's the leader.
She is the leader.
Kuroi Novella, who is this woman?
Kusat.
Funny.
Mysterious.
It's all of that.
Well, let's check out Shiori's cover and cheer her on, okay?
Continuing our news.
There has been some recent suspicions arise around FUWAMOCO and their song choices when it comes to Japanese music.
When examining this tweet and question here, we can conclude that this Ruffian is wondering if maybe FUWAMOCO's maine-chan is making some heavy-handed suggestions and telling FUWAMOCO to sing some pretty interesting classic choices.
You know, with logic that would make sense considering time and age and upbringing heavily influences these sort of things, but there's one big question here.
It's suggesting what content talents make something and Mane-chan do it.
Well, the answer is, for FUWAMOCO, NO!
Mane-chan is there to support their crazy thoughts and ideas.
I wonder when that happens, huh?
Crazy thoughts and ideas never happen, huh?
So, even if you ask Mane-chan what they think, they'll just say, do what you think is best!
As long as it's okay.
But no!
Not even Mane-chan, nor FUWAMOCO's mama puppy, or papa puppy, or grandma puppy, no one can influence their actions!
It's now well documented that FUWAMOCO just have an interesting taste and knowledge when it comes to anime songs and J-pop.
Hm.
Over!
And our next, we have our popular education acquaintance!
Please go have fun!
It's time for Biboo's Japanese Class!
Yay!
Today's Japanese is... Kora!
Nametara akan yo!
Kora!
It means... Beep off!
Don't underestimate me, you silly head!
Let's all continue having lots of fun learning Japanese together, okay?
Rock, rock!
Oh no, what's the matter Nerissa?
I don't know, it's just that recently I've been struggling making thumbnails for streams.
Like, I don't want to make them anymore.
I just want to have fun.
No more cutting and pasting and playing around with fonts and colors and angles.
Yeah, I gotchu.
If only there was an easy answer to making thumbnails.
Oh, are you two having problems?
Yeah, making thumbnails just suck.
Well, in that case, I have just the product for you two!
Oh?
What is it?
Made from 100% professionally aged demon dog, it's Powdered Pero!
Dried in the musty corners at the bottom of the cell,
If you stir in around 100 grams into a hot cup of Rat King tea, you can blast them making a bunch of master quality thumbnails even Picasso would be proud of!
Wow, that sounds great!
It sure is!
Does it just help with thumbnails?
Yeah, what about side effects?
Huh?
Are you implying something, Nerissa?
No, no, no!
How did Pero is perfectly safe!
It's no different from an energy drink, I think.
I love you two.
Why would I ever try to entice you into something questionable, huh?
As for video editing, you betcha!
You'll be able to make any movie you want in a flash!
Vlogs, animation, feature-length films, animal videos.
It's all possible with just a sip of some tea mixed with powdered Pero!
It tastes great too!
You know when you find an old marshmallow on the sofa and you're like, when in the world did I last have marshmallows, huh?
You know, that's exactly the flavor of powdered Pero.
With a combination of confusion and artificial sweeteners, it only adds to your beverage and enhances your creativity.
Amazing!
And the best part, the price!
All it costs you is... Can you guess?
Well, normally it would be $149.99 with shipping and handling, but due to a manufacturing error totally not caused by a certain employee called Fuwawa Abyssgard, that new price is something that will never be beaten in multiple, multiple lifetimes.
All it takes is hitting the subscribe button!
You thought I'd say your smile?
Well!
Now that you've hit that button right, I'll make an even better deal for you!
All it costs is...
Your smile!
Because I need it.
It's my duty to protect it.
You'll give it to me, right?
Absolutely.
You already had my smile.
Only now can you get your own Powdered Pero!
Limited to 1000 grams per pack, Powdered Pero is available now for the next 100 spectator commenters!
Once today's show ends, it will go back forever in the FUWAMOCO Vault.
BAU BAU!
Wow!
That was a very cute and heartwarming Japanese lesson from Biboo!
You know, she'll definitely help us polish up our Japanese skills until they're solid like a rock, huh?
Powdered Pero too!
Sounds like a good rush of creative inspiration!
Wow.
Let's hear what our spectator commenters have to say.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Indeed!
Need it!
You'll take 20!
Well, you're just in luck!
So authentic!
Yes, Power Pero is only the most authentic!
Well, let's continue on to more news!
Our next story is a very exciting one!
hololive English -Advent- will be revealing their first alternate outfits on January 1st!
New Year's outfits!
And that means it's the season of outfit design guessing.
And despite Ms.
Mococo announcing that the New Year's outfits are as cute as fundoshi, there has been a serious lack of serious outfit guesses featuring fundoshi themselves.
Do you not think there's a hundoshi there hiding Ruffians?
Well, since hundoshi might be new to some Ruffians out there, we ask expert elf for help.
According to Expert F, fundoshi are a traditional Japanese undergarment that consists of a single strip of cloth and leaves a lot of the behind exposed to the airing gaze.
But!
It's an important part of Japanese culture!
It is rather shocking to think that there may be so many who think that a fundoshi may not be included in an outfit design, huh?
Well!
Let's turn to hear what our spectator commentators have to say about this.
Hai.
Interesting.
Culture.
Right.
Kusa.
Oh.
Thank you.
Yes.
Expert Elf.
Thank you very much.
Very important.
Kusa.
Thank you, very good comments!
Well, you'll just have to come see the big reveal yourself starting at 5pm PT, 10am JST.
BAU BAU!
And here's today's weather report!
Oh.
Gosh.
This world.
It looks strangely nostalgic, huh?
Today's forecast calls for some nostalgic rain showers.
I think, at this moment in time, everyone is reflecting back on good times!
And hopefully, looking forward to even more new and exciting good times to come to us in the future.
Well, everyone!
Soredewa, kyou mo, ohayou gozaimashita!